so watching these shots of Golem from
back in the day it's like lots of notes
every movie has constraints and you have
to work to those constraints does a
green suit really help that much no
so each one of her eyes is like 10 times
the amount of geometry from Gollum wow
so it's it's crazy
[Music]
thanks to co-pilot for sponsoring this
video what's up everybody it's Christian
I've been keeping you guys updated on my
health Journey up until this point and I
just gotta say copilot has been a huge
game changer it's been helping me stay
really consistent and keeping me really
accountable and actually this past
weekend I just crossed my 50th workout
using the co-pilot program it's
literally the best but don't take my
word for it Jordan here actually has
been doing the co-pilot workout herself
hey Jordan yep there she is why don't
you tell them a little bit about it I
love the co-pilot program I think my
favorite part about this is that it's
super personalized for you they're not
just making random workouts if you want
to hone your arms more than or of your
workouts will be geared towards that if
you're trying to grow your glutes then
you have workouts personalized to that
and then on top of that not only is it
personalized but it's also personalized
for your schedule super flexible working
on your schedule they'll work with you
to see whatever works best say if you're
going out of town for the weekend you
don't have a gym just tell your coach
and they'll make you a workout you can
just do on the floor in your hotel room
wait so you actually have a real life
coach oh yeah her name's Candace and she
lives in Orlando I love her every time I
submit my workout she literally sends me
a video she'll text me saying like great
job how was it was it too hard was it
too easy and you have an Apple Watch
don't you I do have an Apple Watch if
say I'm doing my glute bridges too fast
Kansas voice comes through my air pods
and says you're going too fast literally
like having the personal trainer right
there next to you but starting on your
own schedule
but there is an accountability Factor if
you do miss a workout they'll hit you up
and they'll be like hey I saw you missed
a workout what's going on you're like so
if you're interested in an affordable
Fitness coach program that gives you
personalized workouts accountability and
support from a real life person what
should they do Jordan what they should
do is Click click that link in the
description below to get a free trial to
start your journey with the new health
and fitness coach today you won't regret
it get those games
yes and are working out we have an
oscar-winning VFX artist on the couch
today let's get into it hey what's up
welcome back to another episode of
visual effects artist react today is a
very very special
in here on the couch thank you for
joining us today thanks for having me
Eric and his team at what effects just
won the Oscar for best visual effects
for the CGI Masterpiece that is Avatar
the way of water we talked all about
that film in our last episode with Eric
So today we're going to break down some
of his other well-known films you have
quite a history here I think we should
jump into it on this episode yeah look
at some of these these shots awesome
full
so this was back
Mormon's capture was a thing it was it
was still called motion capture then
there's no rules yet no it was there
were no rules we didn't know what we
were supposed to be doing the balls on
Andy were gigantic and I'm talking about
the ones on his suit sorry
I was unsure
oh she
came and we want it
we would capture him on video the
capture just wasn't all that outstanding
at the time so it was a lot of artists
driven interpretation and from animator
to animator they'd interpret it a little
bit differently so you got a little bit
different performance per shot even we
were sort of figuring it as we went
[Music]
so watching these shots of Golem from
back in the day I have lots of notes
like pretend okay
okay what's your VFX super
visor what do you notice
and like say oh their Shadows look
terrible the density of the Shadows is
wrong how do the edges look wrong when
it's a CG character over a plate it's
it's
then I mean you don't think about it
when you watch Lord of the Rings right
it's like watching Jurassic Park you
don't think about the dinosaurs you just
know they look awesome when you
go back and look at Gollum now it's the
same with the hair right it was solved
as one big thing so when you see it move
you see big strips of it move and you go
oh we can do so much better now but it's
still you still got the character and
you still understood Gollum and you felt
for Gollum so it did the right thing
yeah you guys told the story which like
you're successful in doing and that's
the most important thing exactly they're
getting like you know hyper nitpicky and
Technical detail but hey that's what we
do on the show
dude I wanna I wanna hear more notes he
get another shot of Gollum here and it's
like what are you looking at other than
the shadows for me I look at the facial
right the mouth doesn't work for me
anymore the corners of the mouth I don't
see enough Andy
by the third film we got all the skin
working quite well the look of his eyes
those things and you can see Andy in the
performance a lot better the famous
scene from the third movie where he's
acting across from himself near the pond
I always remember being like Blown Away
by the fact that like you were getting
these excellent performances out of his
face here but this was before all the
dots were put on faces as like a
practice right yeah and so all of that
just had to be used as pure reference
and animators went through and pretty
much just keyed it yeah it had to be and
in this case to keep the two
performances separate of Gollum and
smeagle we actually had one animator do
one and one animator do the other and
the same animator did all the way
through so that you ended up with the
same performance the same interpretation
I think that's why it worked really well
because you ended up with the same idea
across the two that's the one that I
think is the one that really nailed it
so this scene we actually had Andy with
the guys and actually interacting with
them and we had motion capture cameras
on set with us because on The Two Towers
you would have the three of them acting
together but that wasn't performance
capture that was just reference but here
you're talking about this scene filming
and having motion capture yep some of
the early stuff it's a little more rough
because all the motion capture was done
post with Andy on a capture stage doing
it by himself looking at the images
right yeah oh man but if you go to
Hobbit everything was all captured
together and it got much better
interaction so in our these scenes where
like you have a digital character like
grabbing a real person and you had a
real person underneath doing the
performance how do you guys do it how do
you remove Andy circus's hands and put
smeagles there most of the time we have
a digital double of Frodo because we
have to track them anyways even in all
of the Avatar films right you always
have to track the live action so that
you get proper Shadows from that
character onto the CG or to get proper
connection between the two so you end up
with a digital double that you can then
use to paint through the hands and
generate a neck or make whatever you
need to do sometimes it's just a lot of
sitting in front of a computer and
painting frame by frame by frame
throughout all these episodes of VFX RS
react I've slowly come to learn that
it's just grit
the plugin is called effort manual yeah
[Laughter]
so you were in town for the VFX bake off
showing off basically the 10 shortlisted
best visual effects movies leave a
comment down below if you want to see a
little bit more detail on one of those
movies and we'll take a look the clips
for the shortlist were great so there's
lots to talk about in all those movies
what brings you in here sweet so this if
I'm not mistaken you're filming a real
actor and then just basically replacing
everything but their face I've always
liked the concept of just like taking
just the physical face here the thing
that's really hard to do and using that
with footage and everything else can be
CD around it you get the eyes you get
the mouth you get the nose you get all
the performance and then you you just
add the body so in that case you could
almost call it more motion capture
because you're just capturing the body
and you're not getting the performance
of the face I guess I'm just curious
about the blending part of it because
there's a little bit of like
translucency to the edge of the skin so
that would have to be rendered out at
what point does it transition from the
digital face to the footage plate just
outside his eyeball so his forehead is
All Digital really all of this yeah okay
because you have to give it thickness
and you want that subsurface feel so you
need a blend point but you want a blend
Point that's not moving right so just
above his eyebrows the skin stops moving
so you have to find good blend points
where it's not moving and you can get
the two work together were the ears real
are they digital digital that's actually
more of a CG face than I expected same
but it was the only way to really sell
it right like you have to give it
thickness so you can't have it all the
way back here because you want to give
that thickness you want to see the light
through it
foreign
[Music]
you want to get as much of Rosa into a
leader that you can even though she's
got the Giant Eyes you can still see
Rosa in that if you compare one to one
with her performance you really see her
performance in there you see her mouth
moving yeah the same way her nose the
weird little subtleties that she has to
her and the nuances that you would never
think about animating right like the
weird back and forth of her lips or her
eyes flickering a little bit it's all
those subtle things that sell it to
people
[Music]
so obviously this character has very
large eyes larger than realistic human
eyes I feel like that's immediately
gonna walk down the path of uncanny
valley and it's a challenge to make it
not be that problem that's such a fine
line to walk through because you have
like the distance between the eyes and
the relation and the ratio to the nose
it's like being off by just like a
couple millimeters suddenly makes it
being like Oh that's that's pretty cool
looking to
what am I looking at and it's a subtle
distinction so it's yeah I can I can see
how that's a challenge to figure out it
was the biggest challenge for sure we
actually ended up simulating her eyes we
actually took Houdini we built all the
fibers in her eyes like you would
probably have with an eye that is of a
newborn and then essentially simulated
the dilation of the eye thousands and
thousands of times so that Little Fibers
broke and it generated the geometry for
her eyeball with millions of polygons in
each of her eyes so that you got all
that detail in her eyeballs so each one
of her eyes is like 10 times the amount
of geometry from Gollum wow so it's it's
crazy though just in the eyeballs so not
too often we get to sit down on the
couch with somebody as accomplished as
Eric and if you want to get into the
nitty-gritty of these details head on
over to our website for the extended
episode we chill on the cuts we let
things float a little bit because you
know we're not on YouTube anymore there
so yeah go check it out
so the most recent movie you worked on
before Avatar 2 was the Green Knight
from David Lowry yep
we actually flew to Ireland with a
scanner and scanned all these locations
all over Ireland over the course of like
three days it was the most amazing time
and the most horrible weather ever it's
sort of the polar opposite of Avatar
right like it's really gritty all shot
on location it's a little more like Lord
of the Rings was where it's lots of
locations all over New Zealand this is
lots of locations all over Ireland
[Music]
for a movie like this where you're
trying to shoot as much as you can on
location and augment it with visual
effects what were some of the biggest
challenges for doing post-production
here I would say some of the biggest
challenges were just being able to do
the effects you want for the scale of
movie you have like on avatar for
example we had 1700 people working on
Avatar and this movie we had eight so
you have to find ways to make the visual
effects look great but at a much more
reduced scale as far as resources go
like these shots here right of the
Giants instead of doing digital Giants
we actually shot women in makeup on a
green screen at the right angle trying
to get the camera in the right place and
trying to get those to work instead of
doing CG Giants which we do if we were
doing this in Avatar there's a hundred
different ways to do the same exact shot
there's the free version there's the 100
version and the hundred thousand dollar
version yep every movie has constraints
and you have to work to those
constraints I feel like the way you guys
did it for the Green Knight is exactly
how we would have done it yeah because
it's like all right we can't afford to
have a bunch of different mo-capped
giant characters they're supposed to be
basically people anyway let's just shoot
people yeah with cameras
you make it about What story do you want
to tell and how are the visual effects
going to help you or how they're going
to not help you in this case and David's
really he's really good at that about
using it where you want to use it and
using plates as much as you can and even
when the visual effects are like much
more in your face right if you go back
and look at Pete's Dragon
another movie shooting with kids always
fun is that sarcasm yes
because usually you get an actor on set
you shoot the stuff and then you can
bring that actor into the photo booth
and get shots of them and do all those
things when you shoot with kids you tend
to use them for the six hours and then
they have to go straight out and go home
so you don't get any of the visual
effects reference that you usually need
and uh we're usually forgotten first but
then you're blamed first for when it
doesn't work exactly
it's
fun to work on a kids movie because it's
so light-hearted and there's no one
getting their heads chopped off and yeah
no one ever thinks about the artist who
has to make the head come off and all
the reference they have to look at
foreign
visual effects supervisor for peach
Dragon here what are some of the
responsibilities for an onset VFX
supervisor you work a lot with the DP to
understand what the lighting is how the
character is going to fit in there you
have to work with the DP so that they
light for what's going to be in the shot
not just what they see because a lot of
DPS will only light for what they see
they light a shot that has a giant
dragon in it and they light for the
characters in The foreground but then
they might leave their background dark
sure and you need to add a digital
character in the background and you have
to have light to account for that or
you'll never get it to fit you work with
the director for performance in shots
like this where Pete is interacting it
was me in a green suit holding up a big
head
so that we had something to Pat on the
day and they wanted me to do it so that
I got the performance I wanted of the
head and you're like okay
does the green suit really help that
much no
the reality is is there's so much light
there's so much dark the green suits
it's all Roto yeah I feel like that's
one of the biggest misconceptions about
visual effects in the general public is
that they just assume that once you put
green on something it instantly gets
painted out and the background gets
tracked in it's like all you gotta do is
just paint and green it's amazing that
everyone thinks that even people on set
that really should know better well
we'll just paint it green so it's
invisible when we shoot it that's not
how it works at all
you're going to have to Roto it out
anyway so you might as well make it a
color that at least like matches and
yeah and that's something working with
Jim he understands that right when
Jake's sitting on the skim Wing why make
it green all you're going to do is get
green spill through the water and on to
him and onto the hand that you want to
try to keep paint of the right color
we're going to row to it anyway so it
doesn't matter one of the great things
with LED screens now right TV shows like
the Mandalorian where they're using that
to light inside the ship with the LED
screens it's great because you get
proper lighting you get proper
interactions on the reflections and you
don't have to Roto as much so it's great
seeing technology evolve as we go if you
saw Avatar subscribe to this video so I
assume all of you are going to subscribe
it's not too often that we get to have a
VFX supervisor on the couch from weda
especially somebody that's been in the
industry as long as you have so I want
to turn to like a bit of a bit of
futurology for a second here like
looking forwards like the next five
years the next 10 years next 20 years
where are some tools coming down pipe
that you're excited about
and then what do you think visual
effects will be like in 10 or 20 years
from now it's a really tricky one isn't
it because if I knew what the future was
going to be I'd start it now because I'd
probably make a fortune it's really how
all the tools we're using are gonna make
things so much better in the future like
how are we going to make hair better how
are we going to make interaction of
characters the lighting or to do Roto
like can we use deep learning to Roto
all these shots for us I don't know deep
learning puts such a weird spin on
things that we're going to be able to do
things that we can't even think of right
now I always feel like oh we've reached
the top of our game and then something
new comes out I thought our facial and
Elita was great Top Notch can't be beat
and then we came up with a whole new
system for facial that's five times
better I don't know I don't think I
answered the question because I'm not
sure I know the answer anymore
thanks again to our sponsor of this
episode copilot well Eric
showing us your experiences from working
all these movies from the green night to
Lord of the Rings Hobbit it's all it's
also insightful to actually hear
first-person accounts of what went down
because we're always having to speculate
so thanks again oh it's been really fun
being here uh going back to some of
these films I haven't looked at in a
long time oh yeah I'm sure thanks for
watching see you next week